folks love the enthusiasm digging the
energy but do keep in mind it takes a
little bit of
time to do these videos i was at the end
of editing my justice league video
about to do my you know that celebratory
relaxing like ah
i did today's video no trailer to the
batman so back at it we go so we have a
trailer to the batman
movie coming out that i've said very
little about because i
just wanted to wait until the trailer so
trailer's here so here we are but this
trailer yeah
digging the vibe of it i really am it's
like it's like a trailer to the movie
seven
but with batman and as i haven't done
any videos on the batman it's because
i've kept my nose out of it too so i
don't really
know much about the batman so that was a
pleasant surprise to be like oh
riddler awesome i'm a big jim carrey fan
i
didn't really dig his riddler
necessarily
to me the closest thing we've gotten to
a riddler movie
is saw and one of the reasons i dig the
vibe of this movie other than the fact
that it's
i just dig the vibe sometimes it's as
simple as that but i like the fact that
it doesn't feel like batman begins
because that's essentially batman begins
again
i mean i guess he doesn't begin he's
already been batman
but not for that long good point is he's
young batman he's in the genesis of
being batman so it would have been easy
to be like maybe it just feels like
batman begins again but it doesn't feel
like that totally has this
[ __ ] up murder mystery vibe going on
with jeffrey wright as
james gordon which is funny when i i
actually did
hear at a point that he was gordon and
when i see the trailer i
think the same thing i thought when i
heard he was gordon it was like
so he's not lucious fox he's
he's not lucious i only asked because he
would be
perfect as lucious fox but he's not him
all right
fair even like subtlety it's batman's
boots when he walked in they didn't feel
like batman boots they just felt like a
dude who's like look
i haven't been batman long so i just
kind of have these boots these tack
boots
hopefully they work and i really dig
that feeling the genesis of a character
who's just like oh my god he's
the batman but right now he's just you
know the batman i don't know how much
respect he's getting yet
obviously enough to being on a crime
scene but you know what if you don't get
respect you're gonna earn that respect
when you
beat down a thug cause that scene holy
[ __ ] he just krispy creams this guy
he's like i'm all out of silly buddy
you think he says it though you think
he's like i'm vengeance
i am the knight i am batman he might
i mean he started the phrase dad or he's
just like i'm vengeance
i'm working on the name and although
this is the start of riddler catwoman
and oswald cobblepot is joker around
because
they look like joker thugs i mean they
don't have red lips
but that's the only thing missing that
the makeup is the same it still has the
line that
they look like joker thugs if those
dudes and that makeup if they approached
me in gotham i'd be like this is either
a
total homage to cobra kai or your joker
thugs i'm digging the vibe of the fact
that there's this serial killer out
there
who happens to be the riddler and oh
also there happens to be batman in this
world there were a couple times in this
trailer
if i'm just being completely honest and
transparent where i kind of got the vibe
of
gotham that show on tv that watched the
first couple episodes of it i was like
nah
i'm out i did end up skipping season one
watching season two on
and i actually did enjoy gotham anytime
i'm getting vibes from the show gotham
i feel like that more or less speaks to
what gotham
tried to do and what gotha wanted to do
but really couldn't do i'm looking
forward to it i really dug this trailer
robert pattinson he's a great actor we
know that by now he is out of the shadow
of those twilight movies he is respected
he's more than earned it so i'm looking
forward to him as bruce white you know a
thing i do like they actually show the
fact that when he has his mask off
the eye makeup residue is still there
because every batman
should have shown that but none do so
the trailer to the batman have you seen
that
what do you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you